[Musique]
mercedes erra bonjour bonjour vous êtes
la plus grande chef d'entreprise en
france dans le domaine de la pub de la
communication vous dirigez havas
worldwide et vous avait cofondé lagence
b ou tc vous êtes d'origine espagnole et
vous avez changé
pardon catalan en effet bank en espagne
et vous avez changé notre regard sur le
parcours d'une femme issue de
l'immigration alors on va voir avec vous
comment vous en êtes arrivé là mais
avant je voudrais tu mourir l'écran et
vous faire réagir sur ce mot pionnière
c'est un peu vous non alors je pense pas
tous les jours vous fait d'être pionnier
havre mais ce qui m'est arrivé c'est
d'être souvent la première femme qui
première femme qui dirigeait une très
grande agence de communication première
femme qui allait à l'association des
agences conseils en communication et qui
est rentré y avait que des hommes
première femme à devenir la présidente
de cette association
première femme à devenir hec présidente
des alumni c'est qu'ils se concentrent
avec toujours une heure dans quelque
chose aux femmes un peu forcé parce que
je voulais pas que les femmes rentrent
pas c'est il ya des choses qui me
plaisait naturellement il ya des choses
présidente des anciens élèves d' hec
c'est pas un but en soi ce n'était pas
un but en soi mais je trouvais que l'on
manquait vraiment trop de femmes et
qu'il fallait ouvrir les portes vous
êtes né en espagne vous avez immigrés en
france avec vos parents quand vous aviez
5 ans et vous avez coutume de dire que
vous êtes devenue féministe à l'âge de 5
ans ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire j'ai
l'impression que le fait de voir
ma maman mon papa comment comment les
choses se partager entre l'histoire de
ma maman
j'avais plus envie de vivre la vie de
mon papa que celle d'un moment on fait
très très vite j'ai eu l'impression que
c'était plus fatigant ce qu'elle faisait
et moins intéressant est que lui
s'amusait davantage alors que pourtant
et d'aller travailler ont raconté des
choses comme ça ils travaillent beaucoup
mais moi j'ai eu le sentiment que en
fait c'était pas très marrant la vie
qu'elle menait parce qu'on est arrivée
en france elle a eu un déclassement
social c'était on est arrivé en france
en été de la petite bourgeoisie et on
est passé à plus tôt pas aisé quoi mais
avec toujours cette image de la petite
bourgeoisie catalan donc ma maman elle
mettait des belles robes elle était très
jolie et c'est donc la france a été pour
elle un choc mais surtout ce que maman
est pas conformiste et elle n'était pas
idéalement fait pour tenir une maison
s'occuper d'être à l'heure s'occuper de
faire la cuisine elle avait horreur de
ça elle voulait le dire la cantine avec
moi et oui elle était et du coup ça ça
me donnait pas une image conventionnelle
de maman heureuse à la maison et moi
j'avais le sentiment que finalement
c'était assez pénible quand elle était
enceinte jusqu'au bout elle travaillait
on l'a oublié ça quand tu es les filles
sont enceintes on s'arrête quatre mois
tout ça même un moment elle s'arrêtait
pas à les enfants étaient là il continue
à travailler
elles tiennent donc très vite je me suis
dit c'est pas cool là les changes le
partage là c'est pas totalement au point
ayant comme j'étais ça vous identifier
plutôt au fait que votre père lui par
travail il s'est amusé en surveillant
que c'est plus rigolo et je me dis que
je vais avoir une fille rigolote et pour
ça il faut aller à l'école être éduqués
ça va vous aider mais au départ vous
parlais pas un mot de français
évidemment j'arrive en france c'est rien
j'ai 6 ans 6 en fait et je parle pas un
mot de français
je parle même pas espagnol parce que je
parle catalan donc les gens me parlent
espagnol je me dis mais c'est n'importe
quoi j'ai dit à un moment mais tu me dis
ce que je pense
exactement parce que j'avais
l'impression de n'être de nulle part
j'ai un peu moqué de tenter un truc
c'est ma les enfants c'est dur les
enfants sera ça fait pas de cadeau donc
ça se moque vite je m'appelle mercedes
jusque édicules pour une petite fille ou
un petit garçon aimeriez vous appelez
comment martin à l'époque j'avais bien
normal normale normale martin à l'école
martin va à la plage utiliser à un
moment c'est tellement magnifique elle
me regardait avec des grands yeux
martin c'est bien là oui mais et vous
résumer et emmène béant donc face à la
moquerie face au fait que vous ne savez
pas parler français
comment précisément vous allez faire
comment vous allez avoir cette
résilience
non mais c'est assez simple les enfants
c'est toujours quand on les bouge comme
ça et puis quand même j'étais pas en
danger j'avais des parents aimants
savard quoi j'avais à manger tout allait
bien et puis des parents qui qui était
sympa donc je me suis dit si aucune
souffrance non non il n'y a pas de
souffrance
à ce moment là il n'y a pas de sous
c'est comme si il ya quelque chose qui
s'était coupé et que maintenant fallait
avancer qu'on n'allait pas discuter et
donc avancer c'était à prendre ce
magnifique français mais vous allez vous
taire pendant des mois
bah oui parce que je veux pas qu'ils se
moquent donc je me dis je vais apprendre
quand je le saurais je parle vous
apprenez ou france inter vous écoutez
france info et france inter tout le
temps vous avez six ans ouais j'écoute
j'adore le français sont sa magic tiac
la sonorité la musique mail je pense que
nul ne peut aimer autant une langue que
quand on vient de l'étranger
et quand ils cette langue permet
l'intégration à l'imagix cette langue
c'est pas juste une longue c'est que si
je parle comme ça aussi jolie que la
dame qui parle à 9 heures que pierre
bouteiller ou je ne sais trop quoi
si je parle comme eux j'ai gagné et donc
vous allez vous taire et revenir à la
parole en classe lorsque vous aurez tout
intérêt c'est quand même ça comme une
forme de revanche
non c'est
c'est pas dedans c'était simple je veux
pas qu'ils se moquent et à un moment ça
c'est sorti mais je sais même pas quand
comment ces sorties c'était déjà là
c'était toujours la première année
scolaire ils ont halluciné quand ils
vous entendu parler d'eux oui j'ai par
les traders
j'avais pas d'accent du zombie à saillé
moi j'étais première la fin de l'année
scolaire
j'étais première force et donc à force
de travail
vous allez d'écouté d'importance donc
vous allez faire des brillantes études
vous passez votre bac avec mention très
bien et vous avez un rêve devenir
professeur de français vous la petite
catalan veut devenir professeur de
plongée pas choisie c'est-à-dire comme
le français c'était tellement important
je ne me voyais que professeur de
français vous devenu prof de français
votre rêve oui je fais des hypokhâgne et
khâgne donc c'est génial on coule dans
proust ans comme dans tout ça est bien
proche de france et la grève se fracasse
sur la réalité
oui alors c'était pas très grave je me
suis dit mais je suis bon c'était pas
très grave il s'est passé que j'étais
pas fait pour être fonctionnaire j'étais
pas fait
j'avais déjà une attitude très critique
face à l'enseignement c'est à dire bah
c'est elle que je me disais bon ben ça
va il sort adorable les enfants ils
m'écoutent
mais qu'est ce qu'ils comprennent est-ce
qu'on est sort vraiment de là où ils
sont vous essayez de remettre en cause
le programme pédagogique facile à
prendre
cherche je n'ai jamais fait de pédagogie
n'est jamais après on n'a jamais appris
à apprendre
j'ai une assez grande naturalité parce
que j'ai une oralité facile et
d'empathie mais je veux discuter avec
les autres profs personnes tout le monde
se dit c'est la petite chaîne vous vous
trouvez que le système est un peu rigide
à ses fichiers pour moi c'est s'est figé
ça discute pas assez on n'a pas de
projet commun
je me dis hou là vous lui donnez de
l'argent j'imagine je veux gagner de la
wii oui j'aime pas non plus le fait de
deux ans
de ce fait vous avez raison je dis
j'aime pas l'idée que je vais travailler
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
parce que c'est ma nature
et rien ne va bouger alors vous allez
changer totalement d'univers allait
faire hec des études donc de commerce
et puis par le biais d'un stage vous
allez rentrer dans la pub dans une très
grande agence
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse dans la pub
en fait au début rires quand je suis
rentrée c'était comme un monde un peu
abstrait j'avais jamais regardé par
hasard y voilà et puis parce qu on
voyait bien hec que j'avais un certain
nombre pour le marketing
parce qu'en fait le marketing ce gros
mot qui est utilisée c'est la
compréhension des gens donc j'avais des
sciences du maine dernièrement en fait
j'avais une excellente formation parce
qu'on nous pose souvent et en france
tant que j'avais pas fait hec ont
considéré que ces études de lettres ne
m'avait pas structuré en fait c'est le
contraire ce que dira si ce sont ses
études de sociologie de psychologie
littéraire littéraire de dissertation
qui sont très structurante pour ce
métier donc j'ai été armée par mes
études
s'ajoute à cette curiosité pour les gens
rentrent dans un lieu où je m'aperçois
que un décor entre on peut faire bouger
les choses bouger les lignes
j'aime bien ça une campagne de pub où
démarre une campagne pub mais aussi tout
jeune c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas dans
un univers trop compliqué si la petite
jeune elle veut vraiment travailler plus
elle travaille plus et si elle prend la
main elle finit par prendre m
et là c est la conséquence de cela c'est
que très rapidement
vous allez être embauchée par une très
grande agence alors que vous a commencé
comme comme stagiaire et votre patron
lors de votre embauche vous dit c'est la
première fois que j'engage une femme n'y
avait pas de femmes dans les agences à
papa pas beaucoup pas pas tant que ça
allait avec kelly lombard district oui
il y avait des standardistes y avait des
secrétaires mais dans le métier ce qu'on
appelle le métier de la création de la
stratégie c'était plutôt masculin il
ajoute non seulement c'est la première
fois que j'en
j'embauche une femme et en plus ça va
être très difficile pour vous non ça va
être des jeux n'est pas embauché il m'a
dit je n'ai pas embaucher deux femmes
jusqu ici parce que c'est très difficile
encourageant et moi j'ai dit bon bah ça
va si c'est très difficile on va y
arriver mais pas peur non puis ils
étaient ils n'étaient pas antipathique
je les trouve toujours trouvé sympa
après ils étaient étonnés mais ils
étaient étonnés parce qu'il ya de quoi
s'étonner ces drogués pas de fermer une
jeune femme comme ça qui arrive dans un
milieu d'hommes
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est aussi
facile que si vous étiez un mois non
pour moi il s'est rien passé de à ce
moment là c'était très jeune donc il
s'est rien passé de 2001 grave puisque
de toute façon comme j'avais la chance
d'être je ne sais pas moi impliqué par
ma maman par mon papa je ne sais pas je
ne me posais pas de questions
donc j'étais quand même vous observez
bien l'étude désarrimée finalement après
que ça vous touche pas c'est une chose
mais vous observé des comportements
c'est pas là on commence déjà je sens
que mon authenticité plus que d'ailleurs
ma féminité dérange parfois ceux-ci la
vérité donc voilà j'ai pas peur et donc
je dis quand quelque chose d'ouvert je
le dis quand un client me parle mal je
dis non mais ça va pas le faire et donc
c'est tout le monde autour de -
s'inquiètent en disant mais qu'est ce
qu'elle raconte raconte la vérité et
après c'est passionnant parce que c'est
un métier de recherche de sens de
finalement les gens comprennent pas mais
dans la publicité
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis le
début du monde c'est à dire quand on a
fait un produit et qu'on aime bien
on raconte qu'il est bien et si on ne
raconte pas les gens n'acceptent pas aux
produits donc c'est une chose très
importante
est ce assez pour un produit pour une
marque pour un être humain pour les
hommes politiques
donc tout d'un coup je vois des tas de
sujets des sujets de penser des sujets
d'invention de stratégie de création
m'amuse et alors justement la première
campagne qui va vous faire décoller
enfin
qui à la campagne qui va vraiment vous
faire décoller parmi celles-ci wrangler
taillé pour l'aventuré
c'est ma première campagne donc je me
suis battu pour ça parce que en fait les
images fortes ne s'impose jamais
facilement les idées même simple belle
puissantes elles sont toujours
difficiles
ce qu'une idée elle est fragile et là
c'est une idée très simple le jim c'est
un vêtement seconde peau en fait le but
jim c'est que nous ont amené nos
américains qui étaient si différent de
la façon dont ce vtt les français
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient découvert dans
ces lycées américains c'est que le corps
parler et qui s'est exprimée puisqu'il
prenait la forme du jean mais m 1 du
nymphée thuillet du coup pour dire un
peu cette intimité ou cette chose un peu
particulière de ce produit un peu
magique le foetus le raconte
formidablement c'est comme si c'était
tellement liés au corps que on peut
naître avec c'est comme une seconde peau
dans la chambre
non non une campagne ne change pas non
si rien n'a changé ce qui a changé ma
vie c'est j'ai eu la chance de se
trouver mon métier alors j'ai dû me des
très précise de la difficulté des gens
pour trouver leur métier donc je trouve
que c'est une chance de personnes on
m'aurait dit vous êtes tu vas être dans
la publicité j'aurais dit ben non moi
c'est proust donc allez découvrir son
métier
et la deuxième chose c'est que j'avais
la niaque un sens très fort des
responsabilités évoluer votre chemise
c'est assez rare on a souvent accusé la
pub d'être misogyne avec une
représentation des femmes soit femme
objet
soit femme ménagère responsables des
achats
ça veut dire vous avez participé à ce
nom alors pour moi la pub est pas
misogyne elle est la société allait
comme la société c'est un peu quand on
présente aujourd'hui par exemple on peut
pas représenter les femmes ménagères
parce que les femmes ne supporte plus de
se voir comme ça mais l'avait pourtant
si je racontais la vérité chez les
femmes qui font le ménage certes c'est
enfin on a vu quand même certaines pubs
qui donnait quand même une perception de
la femme comme étant une femme objet
regardez par exemple cette campagne dans
les années 80 demain j'enlève le bas
vous souvenez de cette pub c'est pas du
tout pour un maillot de bain c'est pour
un affichage en temps j'entends mais
bien sûr mais je vais vous dire un truc
ça me choque pas ça ça me choque pas
mais ça m'avait fait sourire à l'époque
on n'a plus droit parce que le corps
libre des femmes
ça me choque pas énormément le corps
qu'on l'a les toutes les histoires qu'on
fait aujourd'hui sur ça ça me choque pas
mais ça peut aussi pas une
représentation jeu qui fait de la femme
non ça participe comme toutes les
fictions comme toute la culture a une
image de la femme qui est sa réalité moi
je ne pense pas qu'il faut travailler
que l'enjeu c'est de combattre cela et
c'est de combattre ça l'enjeu c'est de
donner du pouvoir aux femmes
les représentations elles sont
importantes mais elles ont beaucoup
évolué elles ont évolué avec les gens
alors la publicité c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus h dans les représentations
pourquoi parce qu'on est très surveillée
et du coup on n'a pas droit
les fictions ce que vous voyez sur
l'internet est beaucoup plus dure donc
votre parcours est un parcours hors
norme
je le disais vous êtes rentré chez cette
chic et une grande agence comme
stagiaire pour devenir directrice
générale de l'agencé huit ans plus tard
puis ensuite vous avez créé votre propre
boîte bo tc aujourd'hui vous dirigez
près de 2000 personnes
comment est ce que vous avez pété ce
fameux plafond de verre que les femmes
disent subir tellement fortement
lorsqu'elles ont l'ambition
d'abord je ne suis pas sûr
que si j'avais été un homme je ne serais
pas allé plus haut même si le plus haut
je m'en fiche un peu
mais c'est vraiment pas mal aux enfants
non mais je vous assure que je pense que
j'ai été freiné mais je pense même
aujourd'hui et que je ne dirige pas
concrètement tout abbas
parce que vous êtes une femme non je
n'en sais rien je dis que j'ai le
feeling que on a donné à des sommes
beaucoup plus médiocre des choses qu'on
aurait pu me donner
mais après comment vous avez parlé
jusque là alors comment je suis allé
jusqu'à là c'est que j'ai eu la chance
d'abord un j'avais trouvé mon métier
si vous avez du talent pour quelque
chose c'est mieux mais il y en a un qui
s'arrête à l'étagé en dessous et c'est
une chance
la deuxième chose c'est que j'avais un
sens très fort des responsabilités des
du travail
j'aimais ça donc j'avais une passion
pour ça donc ça je pense que on ne monte
pas sans cette passion sans mais en
termes d'égalité de salaire par exemple
après je pense que ce qui a fait la
différence c'est que je n'avais pas
j'avais pas énormément d'angoise dans ma
tête je ne pensais pas que j'allais
échoué dans ma vie privée parce que je
travaillais et ça ça change beaucoup de
choses c'est si j'ai eu un levier
si j'ai une chance c'est celle de dettes
choqué quand on posait des questions
autour de ma réussite privée familiale
et que ces questions n'étaient jamais
jamais jamais posé un homme lancé normal
elle est célibataire mais aussi à la pas
d'enfant comment vous allez faire pour
combien de fois mais même aujourd'hui
que la distinction pour femmes qui se
joue là dessus
attendez je suis convoqué au matinal le
8 mars - matinale de france inter de la
femme va journée de la femme
j'ai pas que ça à dire donc est ce que
ça veut dire que parce que que vous
n'avez jamais connu ce qui va être dit
maintenant nous sommes pas
segal si je bafouille si je me trompe
si je cite des chiffres faux mais
dira-t-on après cette émission nous
dirons nous voyons bien sûr les femmes
on ne peut pas compter sur elle et mon
absence 300 vous voilà simon a dit ébahi
rassure toutes les femmes pour se dire à
ce qui serait injuste parce que
peut-être une autre aurait pu très bien
faire le poids comme on dit en face de
vous mais si vous vous va fouiller si
vous n'êtes pas très bon on peut dire à
ton aux dires abat ce monsieur foyer
n'était pas formidable ce soir et aucun
garde des sceaux ni dans le passé ni
dans le présent ni dans l'avenir n'en
portera la dignité ni aucun homme vous
reconnaissez dans les propos de françois
0 moi j'aime beaucoup les propos de
françois girault
mais oui parce que je pense que moi j'ai
eu la chance pour avancer mon nom et
pourquoi j'ai avancé parce que j'étais
un peu tranquille mais c'est évident que
la dureté extérieur qu'on peut pas faire
exactement la même chose qu'un homme que
à la télévision par exemple lorsqu'on
vous dit mais oui intervenez intervenez
si j'interviens trop brutalement
on va dire que c'est un peu hystérique
donc il faut faire toujours très
attention
donc c'était françoise qui avait dit on
sera à égalité le jour où une femme
incompétente dirigera quelque chose je
crois fortement
je crois que mon faites moi je suis et
c'est pour ça je me suis battue sur les
quotas moi je veux pas du côté femmes
dans les habillages heures et notamment
dans les contenus nistration et même au
plus haut niveau pour moi j'ai pas du
tout je pense qu'il ya eu des quotas
donne jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était 100%
donc on va pas maintenant sans voix
c'est parce qu il ya quelqu un quota de
femmes et pourquoi je me suis battue
parce que je voulais pas que toutes les
femmes soient obligés de me ressembler
pour réussir moi je suis très
travailleuse
je dors pas beaucoup est ce que c'est ça
qu'on doit aller raconter aux femmes que
pour réussir faut qu'elle soit comme moi
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que les choses naturellement
montrent des femmes et des hommes
je crois la mixité et je crois que ça
c'est un levier mais est-ce que vous
souffrez par exemple de certaines formes
de d'inégalités encore par exemple sur
le salaire non là je ne souffre plus
mais je me suis âgée souffert parce que
je ne m'étais pas rendu compte qu il
inégalité donc j'avais combattu j'ai
combattu et bien sûr quand je les ai
découverts mais je les combattu mais
chez je vais pas gagner entre guillemets
il ya eu quand même de l'argent qu'elle
donne n'est pas gagné d'accord alors
vous avez une singularité parmi deux
fautes c'est que votre conjoint et père
de vos enfants ne travaillent pas c'est
un homme au foyer est ce que ça vous a
aidé pour votre carrière
en partie oui après en partie pas autant
que ne l'imaginent les gens c'est
derrière que la légende voudrait que cet
homme soit comme une femme qui règle
tous les problèmes de la maison et bien
la légende ne marche pas mon homme et un
homme et donc et toute l'organisation de
la maison elle est quand même fait
beaucoup par mois elle a été moi j'ai
été beaucoup aidé par des nounous donc
par les femmes
là où ge ou jean-paul moi j'aurais
préféré très honnêtement que si on peut
le travail parce que moi je ne n'arrive
pas à regarder à penser que ce qui est
bien pour moi n'est pas bien pour
l'autre l'opac modèle inverse et manon
je pense que c'est intéressant lé
équilibre dans la vie entre la maison le
travail et c'est lui a voulu rester
après ça m'a donné certains avantages
une inquiétude quand je rentrais tard
et puis vous avez incarné quelque chose
en terme d'image oui puis ça a aidé ça
aide bien sûr ça a beaucoup aidés
les mêmes les garçons je te dis c'est
quand même intéressant d'imaginer que
c'est possible d'inverser voilà c'est
intéressant parce qu'on a on doit faire
avancer les images de cet ordre donc
c'est intéressant et vous avez
l'impression que les hommes évoluent
aussi par rapport à ce que vous renvoyez
est bel et bien sûr les femmes et les
hommes ont évolué et 7 ces émissions qui
ont eu lieu qui ont montré ça combien de
fois j'ai été arrêté pour me dire merci
pour ça donc d'une certaine façon le
parcours de votre parcours devient une
forme de manifeste féministe
ça aide ça en fait le fait d'être
concret d'être humble et de raconter sa
propre histoire a aidé à dire à beaucoup
de femmes c'est possible alors vous
managez des hommes des femmes je le
disais et on a beaucoup parlé récemment
de la problématique de mitu avec
l'emprise des hommes sur les femmes dans
sur le lieu de travail
on sait assez peu de choses sur ce qui
se passe dans votre domaine qui est
celui de la pub et de la communication
ça veut dire qu' il n'y a pas de sujet
là dessus il ya un sujet partout demi
tour mais un sujet dans toutes les
boîtes avec qui je travaille dans les
agences etc
donc il ya un sujet bien sûr il ya les
jeunes à regarder
regardez les chiffres ont été confrontés
moi j'ai été on a été confrontés à des
cas mais après
si vous êtes très strictes vous mettez
d'or vous êtes très violent si vous êtes
très claire les gens ont peur et ça se
calme et en tant que manager comment
vous avez vous appliquer la loi
c'est à dire vous séparer de gens qui
font ça fait d'être une femme
le sentiment d'avoir pris davantage
conscience de ce gt dans moi j'étais
dans une agence mixtes c'est à dire que
mon associé est un homme et on n'a
jamais accepté ça je pense que les
règles qu'on a mis dans l' agence c'est
une règle de pouvoir partager
donc ça change les choses le pouvoir est
partagé
moi ce que je n'aime pas dans le
contexte a mis tout c'est très important
mais moi je n'ai pas envie de parler que
des femmes en tant que victime
moi ce que je veux c'est leur donner la
force pour qu'elle puisse pas devenir
des victimes
ça me fait froid dans le dos quand
j'entends qu'il a fallu 20 ans pour
qu'elle dise
coucou le monsieur là ils ont dérangé
vraiment mais c'est quoi cette histoire
en 20 ans mais c'est la culpabilisation
exercer ce qui m'agace c'est que je
pense qu'il faut doter les femmes le
l'enjeu c'est de doter les femmes de
culture de colle de pouvoir quand on va
avoir fait ça ça n'empêchera pas tout
mais ça empêchera beaucoup de choses je
pense que une des façons de se sortir de
ça c'est d'encourager des fab à ce
qu'elles soient libres indépendantes
qu'elles puissent ça va pas tout régler
ensuite on règle les problèmes aussi par
la loi je suis très partisane de la loi
ont lancé des campagnes de pub j'aurai
beaucoup participé à toutes les
dernières campagnes pour les femmes
battues
parce que c'est un drame le féminicide
on utilise les mots qu'on n'a jamais
utilisé féminicide tout ça c'est
important
qu'est ce qui fait que vous n'avez
jamais eu peur je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
pas peur j'ai été fait pour être
confrontés à du dur est donc très vite
la responsabilité familiale je lui ai
pris ma maman quand elle allait pas bien
seul à secouer elle me le racontait
l'hme
mais tu me disais voilà je vais faire
c'est long à faire ça ensemble donc ça
séchait identitaire et le reste glissant
sur vous et j'étais l'aîné donc j'ai
développé un sens de la responsabilité
est très fort très très intenses trop
intense parfois du temps en temps je me
cachais pas responsables quand même de
tout je n'ai jamais mais la plainte
je n'allais pas me plaindre parce que
les petits garçons se moque et moi à
quoi je m'en fiche et je me disais
comment on fait pour résister dont papa
être victimes et faire les chauffeurs
les choses avancent le mot que je là où
c'est très difficile pour moi c'est
quand on m'empêche de faire et
d'ailleurs je pense que le pouvoir ne
sert qu'à faire et que de temps en temps
quand je sens que le pouvoir c'est autre
chose que le faire je m'agace après je
dis ce que je pense donc j'ai dit ça
j'ai souvent j'ai souvent raconté que je
l'avais pas d'admiration pour des gens
qui étaient au dessus de moi et qui
croyait qu'il était très important parce
que c'est pas ça pour moi l'important
c'est les êtres humains la dame qui fait
le ménage
le monsieur qui réfléchit à comment
construire un mur dans le concret demain
l'avenir c'est quoi on va continuer à
faire en a plein de choses à faire j'ai
le musée des migrations c'est absolument
formidable donc vous allez présider le
temps je suis la présidente c'est un
vrai enjeu moi je crois que là au delà
de ça augmente mais non ya pas deux
autres au delà s'il n'y a pas au-delà il
faut faire il faut continuer à
construire il ya plein de choses qui
vont pas
et moi j'aime bien en est quoi ne pas
dire que ça va pas donc en être à jamais
faut aider on est faut se battre là
elles veulent
on me dit mais y'a rien à régler et rien
n'est réglé sur les droits humains des
femmes
il ya urgence qu'on s'y mette tous il
n'y a rien de réglé sur l'éthique un peu
oui c'est moi je mets moi je crois
beaucoup que quand on est dans le civil
comme moi on a une puissance politique
extrêmement importante
on peut faire que la loa quotas elle
passe on peut faire que finalement
on lutte pour agir sur les événements et
agir sur le faire le jeu quatre choses
et ça c'est bien merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]